foreign
[Music]
blackpink's Jenny giving blinks a scare
walking off stage mid concert I think
we've come
to a point where we kind of laid back
and kind of share
yeah the unfiltered real versions of us
now we don't exactly know what's going
on with Jenny all blackpink's management
YG Entertainment will say is she left
the group's Australian performance on
Sunday due to her deteriorating
condition and while Jenny attempted to
finish out the show YG tells E.T on site
Medics advised her against it to ensure
she receives ample rest and stability
[Music]
thank you
as of Monday Jenny seems to be okay her
management speaking on her behalf
assuring everyone she'll recover as soon
as possible
[Music]
the rest of blackpink reportedly told
the crowd Jenny was feeling unwell the
entire day now the group has a couple
days rest before they're set to take the
stage again this weekend but it's
unclear whether Jenny will join them
thank you
the health scare comes as their extra
eyes on Jenny she's getting lots of
attention for her acting debut on HBO's
The Idol guess what Nikki wants to sign
me Nikki Jocelyn's label
great Jenny plays Diane on the show a
backup dancer for Lily Rose Depp's pop
star Jocelyn who has Hollywood dreams of
her own
huh Josh you got this
Jenny you were literally a K-pop Idol so
did you give Lily any advice when it
came to performing as Jocelyn did you
give her any K-Pop Idol tips I remember
we did have this conversation like long
time ago I don't know what what which
tip that I said okay you know obviously
like I'm not a pop star I don't know
anything about this world and everything
so you know any kind of insight into
just like you know just what it's like
to be in those shoes and everything is
always helpful I actually got to see a
black thing and Jenny live not that long
ago and it was so much fun
recording each other and like always
rooting for what they've got going on in
their lives and it seems like Jenny's
bandmates are her biggest cheerleaders
through it all when I was filming for
the Idol last year it was while we were
filming the music video for our latest
album Born pink so they just checked in
on me every day they would call me when
I was in LA shooting just making sure
that I was doing all right on my own and
like today Jesus texted me saying you
look beautiful I'm so happy for you and
it's like oh yeah it's like a nice
family that we have
[Music]